most of you may have seen the reports
from reuters this morning
anti-fascist protesters vandalized
buildings in portland and seattle
they report anti-government and
anti-fascist protesters in portland and
seattle vandalized a democratic party
office
and other buildings and scuffled with
police on wednesday
protesting against president joe biden's
inauguration people dressed in black and
with their faces covered broke windows
in the glass door at the democratic
party of oregon business office in
portland
spray painting an anarchist symbol over
the party sign video posted on social
media showed
we don't want biden we want revenge for
police murders
imperialist wars and fascist massacres
read
a banner they marched under the new
democratic president was sworn in on
wednesday
urging unity and restoration after
republican donald trump's divisive
tenure donald trump was so divisive when
uh you know joe biden
started his presidency by saying this
country is being torn apart by white
supremacists and nativists and
sounded an awful lot like he was calling
the other half of the country
deplorables if you know what i mean so
spare me this rhetoric about you know
biden being the one who truly does want
unity i'll respect him trying to tone
things down
but at least i can say this he used and
abused and is tossing out antifa
the democrats defended him what was that
was that meme you mentioned luke
in toy story there's a scene where the
toys are being thrown out and right now
there's a meme going around with the
toys being blm and antifa
and the the big you know the the child
in there being of course joe biden
throwing them away
throwing him in the garbage the real
test though is when and if these antifa
members get arrested is his campaign
going to continue to bail them out of
prison because that's how you really
know if he's done with him or not
yes because kamala harris also was
raising funds for
a lot of the rioters that broke the law
and and also what's really interesting
is you know we had the mainstream media
hyperbolically screaming about the
potential of violence at all the
50 capitals that's coming our way they
were they were screaming about it at the
highest
decibel of annoyance possible but now
we do have violence but there's a
different kind of violence that just
gets totally swept under the rug no
one's talking about this what do you
like what's going on here
it's ridiculous conservatives are aware
of the double standard
and i'm sorry but saying there's a
double standard is pointless
at right now and the republicans are
more than happy to stand to stand to
attention for the democrats
to help them pretend to provide balance
to their agenda
so mitch mcconnell with his you know
turtle smile well i'm trying to look
rightful for job
and there you go that's it he stands up
he claps and cheers
all these republicans are clapping and
cheering yay the democrats won and
there's no one actually fighting for
conservatives
no maybe a couple people and it's not
even necessarily conservatives but like
just against the left you have this faux
resistance
so what's happening now in my opinion
and it would it could have gone either
way you know
i thought joe biden was going to throw
them a little bit more red meat maybe
throw them a bone
to placate them but i guess these people
just want chaos
so it's really funny because when we saw
them destroying the windows at the
democratic party hq
these viral videos on twitter someone
tweeted
that it was just like what the us
normally does
funding terrorists in the middle east
who then eventually turn on us and start
causing damage to
right nephi so the mujahideen for
instance and then al qaeda
so they they get these antifa people to
go around smashing everything up
they say oh no look at trump's america
and now that it's biden's america
and they go around smashing things up
it's like yeah they're at fault
there was tear gas deployed in major u.s
cities hold on hold on hold on
this was joe biden's gestapo stomping
out
anti-racist and and pro-freedom
protesters anti-fascists anti-fascists
they were just trying to help
and joe biden's gestapo stomped them out
which is again a 180 degree turn
from where we were six months ago where
tom cotton wrote a new york times
editorial police
piece talking about how we need to send
in the military to deal with black lives
matter
huge controversy the new york times
editor got fired because of
allowing an opinion but forced to resign
yes or i should say he resigned in shame
as i say potato potato uh you know what
went on you know what happened there and
now there's
it's a big controversy it's not even
it's not even even talked about
but i remember seeing one of the antifa
signs saying we don't want to bide in
administration we want vengeance yeah i
have a picture i believe
yes and it's a pretty visceral picture
but people need to understand
the larger base of antifa are not big
biden supporters i don't think they ever
were
in the first place they weren't yeah and
so this is one of the issues i had with
high-profile conservative personalities
that would say like anti-fuzz the
militant wing of the democrat party and
i'm like no they hate democrats
they will punch a liberal in the face
but but democrats were eager to defend
them as long as they were making trump
look bad
crazy yup dangerous dude and now well
what are they gonna do
look at the middle east with obama and
isis it's like
it's perfectly on on uh uh uh you know
it's on brand on brand there you go yeah
it's exactly their game like when you
use an evil demon
i'm sorry i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry i just
saw this
we are ungovernable uh-huh literally
technically correct there's you know
what i think there's
there's anarchists like these people who
are more like
some kind of rabid skunk
you're like you know cause the kungs are
like all black you know i mean like
they're wearing all black
and then they like they run around and
you can't do anything with them because
they're rabid and that's the kind of
anarchist they are
and you have people like luke who are
like i would like to use bitcoin to buy
guns and that's the other kind of
anarchist i guess non-aggression
principle
and allowing people to you know transact
peacefully in a way that benefits them
without transgressing
on anyone's personal liberty or
sovereignty or freedom did i say buy
bitcoin with guns
because i guess that would still work
yeah yeah yeah here's a gun one bitcoin
please people do that
that that has happened there's many
interesting aggregate
aggregate transactions that happen all
the time i guess you would be selling
the gun for bitcoin
it's a common transaction in galt's cult
happens all the time
yeah we don't want biden we want revenge
for police murders imperialist wars and
fascist massacres
and you know if you ask them they
probably can't tell you what that means
yeah somebody made a statement most of
those people are foot soldiers just
enraged
angry because they're not making any
money they can see the the economy
spiraling out of control and
that's about
no they want money printed they're the
ones who are like print more money and
give it to us
it's like but prices are going up like
everyone sees that
yeah but it's because of them it's
because it's it's like could you imagine
someone being like we should put
peanut butter in the gas tank and you're
like that'll break the car and then when
the car breaks
more peanut butter the car is breaking
i'm so angry and you're like you put
peanut butter in the gas tank dude
machine doesn't work that way but also
another interesting facet to understand
here
you know they're going to eat their own
they're going to be fighting each other
as i was
saying uh you know a long time on this
show but another one
is you know a lot of them think that
they were promised police reform
and that's nowhere to be seen a part of
this new biden administration
not that i've seen i haven't seen any
clutter or conversations or talk about
any kind of
reforming of the police or authorities
and that's kind of their major they put
the militant
prosecutor in as vp yeah yeah yeah yeah
yep they put 25 000 troops in dc
they started putting up thank you police
officer signs all over dc
did didn't pelosi want uh quote crew man
mckin guns man crew man to machine gun
gendered in that situation it was
threatening to them
right but what this justice department
is more than likely going to be doing is
going to your neighborhood police
departments and hitting them with
lawsuits because there are allegations
to somebody getting mistreated when the
cop was just doing his own job
so that's a real fear in terms of how
they're going to affect policing
where you live in your neighborhoods by
interfering with the way your local
police operations are
and also with the attorney general right
we recently saw in new york with the
attorney general
actually going after the nypd for their
handling of blm protesters
so that's another case that's happening
they they
exacerbated the problem a problem that i
mean luke you and i have been
complaining about for a decade now since
back when when the black block anarchist
types were going around smashing stuff
there was a moment where a dude was
stalking me and then physically attacked
me and luke
grabbed his mask yeah well me and matt
intervened because i saw him kind of
going after you and i was like okay let
me stay
close to tim because i see they're going
to try to attack him and that's when
they kind of jumped at you for
live streaming behind you and as soon as
they got behind you me and matt kind of
jumped in and you know where was it take
care of that situation new york
nine years ago nine years ago and uh i
mean
what else did people expect if you if
you normalize
violence politically what did you think
was going to happen and now
the democrats the bidens they have a
huge
huge situation that's very explosive
right in their hands
that they cultivated themselves thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you